finally tonight there are moments in the
television news business that transcend
the headlines to touch a single heart
our own shannon bream heard the story of
11 year old emilio put shown and shared
it on twitter dying from cancer Emilio
who wanted to be a movie director asked
for one thing to hear from his favorite
Hollywood superheroes and they responded
in droves to know that he only had a
couple of days and this was all he
wanted and to see all these people from
Hollywood who don't know us who don't
know his family step up and send us
these sweet personalized encouraging
videos to him it makes me see there's so
much good in the world and good in
people well today emilio lost his battle
against nf1 cancer but not before he saw
some of those videos Shannon tells us
Emilio's twin brothers seen in this
video from the genes foundation are
grieving a tough day but very grateful
for the outpouring from his super
friends and let me tell you two things
one shannon bream is a fantastic person
just salt of the earth and two if we
could all do just one thing every day
for somebody else
just imagine